do you want to get possibly the best
gaming monitor money can buy at the
moment then the alienware aw 3423 dw
monitor is probably on the top of the
list right now if you're like me and
have been hunting for the perfect
monitor to pair with your awesome 3080
or 3090 gpu this alienware qd oled
represents the apex of what's available
in the market right now hello everyone
i'm gerald and today i will be reviewing
the alienware aw 3423 dw monitor we
cover plenty of topics at geek culture
so the next video might be different
from this one so before you go thanks
for dropping by hang around and
subscribe if the content kills your
fancy look no further this monitor
impresses right out of the box and
anyone who has set eyes on it in real
life will agree with the assessment
from general productivity creative work
and of course gaming this monitor excels
at every single task so what's stopping
you from buying one for starters having
a powerful graphics card to pair along
with this monitor might already be a
non-starter
plus the price depending on where you
live might be a cause for concern as
well
in the u.s the price for this monitor is
1299 us dollars
whereas in singapore that jumps up to
2429
that's a big markup with prevailing
exchange rates unlike other premium
products that offer little other than
brand prestige the alienware aw 3423 dw
will not invoke bias remorse so let's
proceed and find out why this monitor is
just so impressive finding the perfect
monitor in 2021 was not an easy task
which is why some folks myself included
turn to lg's standard lineup of oled tvs
to find a solution however placing a
massive 48 inch television is not
something that is an optimal solution
for many users after all
you need to worry about finding the
right desk to place the tv on
which is why computer monitors still
have their place when space is a concern
specs wise the alienware aw 3423 dwi
monitor is a 34 inch qd oled display
panel made by the folks at samsung
outputting at an aspect ratio of 21x9
with a native resolution of 3440 by 1440
means that if you're looking to stream
on this display the ultra wide format is
not in your favor qd here stands for
quantum dot display technology which
samsung has been focusing on to
challenge lg's dominance in the space
with this alienware monitor
samsung has found a champion for its
course
combine that with cinema grid color
coverage with 1000 nits peak brightness
and visa display hdr trueblack 400
certification this means gaming will
never look the same once you have laid
eyes on this monitor with g-sync
freesync 175 refresh rates and a 0.1 ms
response time alienware has ensured that
they won't be accused for cutting
corners at this price point
box wise we have display port 1.4 b
5 usb 3.2 ports and 2 hdmi 2.0 ports
facing downwards on the left yes in 2022
were still being provided hdmi 2.0 ports
in a premium monitor so if you're
looking to get the most out of this with
a ps5 or xbox series x it's best to
dampen those expectations because the pc
environment is where this alienware
monitor absolutely excels at talking
about pcs here's the word from today's
sponsor here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
and now let's head back to more chill
vibes
playing games at hdr turned up is an
experience that everyone should look
forward to at some point in the future
sadly not many games at the moment do
hdl particularly well the ones that do
in a formal forza and halo infinite are
simply amazing with forza to take a look
at how the reflections on water look and
how much detail there is to be admired
from the sky to the environment it is a
joy to play the game in full graphical
quality and still achieve high frames
making the experience nice and smooth
even with plenty of panning and action
all around
in doomy tunnel with hdr turned on this
monitor performs brilliantly as well
there's no discernable screen tearing
and is a delight to play the game with
this monitor
much of this has to do with the monitor
being one of the few g-sync ultimate
monitors in the market at this point of
time allowing for stunning hdr while
delivering high frames with low latency
gameplay this contrast can be appearance
when playing the same game on a pc
versus the xbox series x with the case
of forza it's still pretty close when it
comes to the experience overall but
you'll be missing the ultra wide
experience it played on the pc and the
increased frame rates as well naturally
the graphics are far superior on the pc
but for a game like forza you aren't
exactly hanging around that often to
look at the scenery when it comes to
achieving rich blacks the monitor has no
problem sending contrasts and levels
most commonly associated with oled
panels
this might be pedentic but given the
cost of this monitor you want it to be a
one-size-fits-all solution
at this point there are few rivals out
there which can match the monitor's
performance but not its cause
these come in a form of the acer
predator x35 and asus rog swift
pg-35vq
both cost more than 2000 us dollars but
have va panels on the other hand the lg
ultra gear
gp 950 g comes the closest in terms of
cost but the real challenge on the
horizon comes in the form of lg's
upcoming oled c2 displays and our g
swift oled keeping monitors
so if you're looking for the best
monitor to get off the shelf at this
juncture nothing else really comes close
to the alienware in terms of performance
the best part of it all is that the
monitor comes with a 3 year warranty
that even covers burn in
this policy really does give you peace
of mind when using a qd oled panel when
one needs to juggle with the persistent
taskbar and icons on the desktop
honestly
if you have been looking for a pc
monitor like i have the alienware aw
3423 dw monitor is definitely the best
piece of hardware you can get at the
moment it's a stellar piece of hardware
that's perfect for the pc environment
and there's little chance you encounter
any form of buyer's remorse
at
1299 us dollars it's well priced but for
folks in singapore the
2429 dollar price tag might cause some
to pause and consider
but if you have made it this far into
the review
you're probably just finding more
reasons to justify the purchase
for now i'll try my best to keep on
looking at as many monitors as possible
to get an idea what will be the best to
get for 2022 and beyond i'm jarrah from
geek culture and i'll be happy to answer
any questions about the monitor in the
comment section below i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
you